want to know what's heating up theaters  this weekend action Bruce Lee's legend  comes alive in birth of the Dragon their  technique is impressive fight me except  I'll challenge in All Saints a new  pastor teams up with new refugees to  build their future together we are not  where we started we're somewhere  completely new I'm gonna be everything I  want to be  we're in leap an orphan girl leaves her  French village for Paris with dreams of  becoming a prima ballerina  see what's hot in theatres with this  week's fan tissa patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]